evil can be guarded against stupidity
cannot and the world's few evil people
have little power without the help of
the world's many stupid people as a
result stupidity is a far greater threat
than evil now this doesn't make them any
less culpable like it's still awful but
this presumption that there is a shadowy
organization sacrificing children's
blood and drinking adrenochrome and
Shadow Banning you on Tick Tock doesn't
seem that realistic to me you can't have
it both ways you can't have it that the
government is completely incompetent and
inept and also the government have
managed to collude themselves and
collaborate in order to stop my
Instagram posts from reaching as many
people as I think that they do but the
bottom line is that people will forego
principles and rationality if it means
keeping their job almost everybody of
compromised their values at some point
in their lives in order to appease a
person in power or do whatever it is
that they need to do to keep food on the
table even if the table is very long and
expensive and in Beverly Hills